isn't it amazing that in 2018 things
looted by imperialist Brits are still
being shown off in our museums and
galleries the British Museum enjoys 700
artifacts plundered from baleen in 1897
as well as the largest gold works from
the Ashanti Empire in Ghana which is
part of mine and June's family's
cultural heritage
there are also precious artifacts from
Ethiopia Greece and we were reminded
this week priceless objects from the
Solomon Islands a feast trough looted
during a punitive raid by Captain Edward
Davis in 1891 has just gone on display
in the Royal Academy islanders concerned
that they are unable to build a full
collection of their own heritage in
their own nation are demanding its
return this should not even be a subject
of debate where is the moral dilemma in
returning stolen property to its
rightful owners Frances president
McConnell has says Europe has a
responsibility to return such artifacts
but the best we have come up with is a
suggestion for loans loaning things back
for the people who are their rightful
owners
patronizing colonial and just not good
enough okay well that was strong
look I my views on this have softened a
bit actually
and the way in the following way I might
my gut instinct would have been to say
to you it's unpractical and unworkable
to do this I'm now a lot more
sympathetic to why people are so hungry
and that's after having looked at some
of the stuff that's in the museum's but
also thinking about it in the following
way and by the way you didn't mention
the Kohinoor which is in the crown
jewels right which is the you know the
diamond in the crown jewels and it was
taken from India and I thought about in
the following way
if you take the algún marbles right they
are something of cultural significance
as great and grand and meaningful to
Greece as stone henges to us right
imagine somebody stole Stonehenge from
the United Kingdom we would you know
want it back and the only difference of
course with the Elgin marbles is they
weren't stolen they were granted by
another occupying power the Ottomans
when they were
in Greece for roughly 400 years legally
by the law at the time and that's one of
the complications around it but the
sentiment I think remains when you've
got something I think that defines the
very essence and identity of a
civilization say the pyramids and
Nefertiti Queen Nefertiti in Egypt the
alkyd marbles from Greece Stonehenge in
Britain you know the Benina bronzes if
they dare I say the Queen Aubrey if they
cut to the to the core actually less so
with a quarry no because it doesn't
define India as much as say the Taj
Mahal does but imagine the Taj Mahal
right if they cut to the core of what
that civilization sees itself as you can
feel you can you've got to I think be
able to sympathize with why they feel
looted historically they were of course
looted and so you've got to have some
sympathy with it even though someone
like me would say how is it practically
workable how can we do it well I think
part of the problem with the Elgin
marbles practically is from a leap with
my legal hat on how far do you go with
the notion that if something was was
legally granted at the time but then
that regime that granted it is no longer
recognized how far back do you go with
that this is what the British Museum
actually says about the Elgar models
Lord elgin's activities were thoroughly
investigated by parliamentary select
committee in 1816 and found to be
entirely legal following a vote of
Parliament the rich museum was allocated
funds to acquire the collection the
British Museum is relying on an
investigation 8 and 16 in a regime that
existed at a time when slavery was legal
in the Caribbean when women weren't
allowed to vote when children were sent
up Jimmy the complete and it's worth
noting that the Ottoman regime only
ended in 1820 so that investigation
would have been conducted while the
Ottomans were still there morally I
understand the idea that it was legal at
the time but this is a question of
morality and I think it's quite clear
that a moral standards I mean I'd like
to see somebody put Stonehenge up and
take it away from you but let's just
have a quick butchers or historian and
author
don't Malaga have to say and the
non-school cut the points from Brazil
people often raised questions about the
Elgin marbles or the Bayeux Tapestry or
the Benin bronzes but in fact the issue
much more is about the fact that I
move around the world and museums give
us the opportunity to open windows onto
the world rather than just look into
mirrors of our own world so if we want
to be able to go to museums and see
objects from all around the world in the
context of the evolution of humanity
then these museums have really important
places and they need their collections
right so let's say we look at ourselves
or this is my argument
we're telling history how it is and
those items ended up in this country
okay do you want me now to trawl around
the whole world and bring back all our
canons pick up all our dead and bring it
back
we've got canons all over the Caribbean
if we just went around the closed all
that history down for them random cannon
this is something that is a foundation
like a random object it's something that
defines the identity but I would have
thought you would understand that
because this is we all know the best way
to destroy a culture is to destroy the
symbols that they associate with that
culture it's like what Isis has been
destroyed
more more confiscate or steal and and
let me just say what was destroyed let
me actually pick up what the British
Museum have said in relation to this and
what they've said is the museum is a
unique resource for the world
the trustees learned extensively all
over the world and over four million
objects from the collection are
available to study online the Parthenon
sculptures are a vital element of this
interconnected world connection they are
part of the world's shared heritage and
transcend political boundaries but
what's that going to do of anything the
original owners are saying that when the
map show what do you think about this
well my first thing is one of these days
I'm going to give you a challenge to say
something to pick a topic about
something good that Britain does that's
my my first challenge all know wonderful
things my second thing is I just think
this is so it is so complicated because
it's common sense if I take something
from you it's not mine and if I'm a good
person I need to give it back even if I
want that's basic common sense but
obviously as we've just been saying I
don't think your fellows argument stood
up too much because all
he's talking about is you should be able
to demonstrate and share and educate
people using objects for example and you
can do that by learning or sharing you
don't need to have ownership to be able
to do that so for me his argument didn't
really what we needed to be touching on
but I think that it is challenging
because to your point how far back in
history do you go if I own something and
I give it to you and then I'm gone and
I'm out the window whose word then
stands as to whose that is but to then
your point when you mentioned Isis I
think that was quite interesting because
I remember well we all probably remember
watching footage of Isis destroying
temples temple and it affected me and
why did you look at it we were doing it
it wasn't Michael it yeah it wasn't my
culture that they were destroying but I
felt for the people who respected a lot
of these raids like the bin Ian bronzes
or the Summer Palace in Beijing they
were completely destroyed you know the
artifacts we have are all that's left
and the British went in and destroyed
people's heritage and they did that as
you said Jesus it was a way of
subjugation when you destroy their
heritage in history it breaks the
putting in the boy academies we sell
this just have to say the Royal Academy
has said issued a statement they said
the Solomon Islands feast trough is
included in the exhibition because it is
an outstanding and innovative expression
of a customary form but also in order to
honestly acknowledge a confrontational
moment in interactions between
colonizers in this case the British and
Islanders we support debates around the
questions that exhibitions of this kind
generate that doesn't address the
ownership issue so your point Phil just
because something ended up here doesn't
mean it was correct so eight five
thousand-year-old artifacts have
recently been returned to Iraq to your
point about Isis they ended up here but
that doesn't mean they should stay here
so I don't think that directly addresses
the last word on this because the Royal
Academy is is saying it's showing a
confrontation the confrontation is
continuing thanks the exhibition and
this is what the people whose heritage
it is think about it a large number of
the country's authentic cultural
artifacts both sacred and artistic are
held overseas many of these cultural or
breath objects represent the remaining
traces of the country's disappearing or
extinct cultures their gradual or system
repatriation would help restock and
restore the country's cultural treasure
and I think we are in a good position as
any other country to understand put them
back I think we could and have they done
an official request this one in the bud
right